six years and ten months the
ecuadorian people have guaranteed the human rights
of mr assange and have covered
his daily needs in the
facilities of our embassy in
london when i assumed the presidency of
ecuador this was the situation and we dictated
a coexistence protocol that is the
minimum  that someone demands from a guest
that he receives in his home ecuador complied
with its obligations under
international law mr. assange
repeatedly violated
express provisions of the conventions on
diplomatic asylum of havana and caracas
despite the fact that he was requested in several
On occasions that it respects and complies with said
norms, it particularly violated the norm of
not intervening in the internal affairs of
other states.
The most recent alert in this regard
would be in January 2019 when wikileaks
leaked documents from the Vatican.
Key members of this organization visited
Mr. Assange before and after.  of said
leak this and other publications
they have confirmed the suspicions that
the world has that mr. assange is still
linked to wikileaks and therefore
with the meddling of this
organization
in the affairs of other states regarding the
behavior of mr. assange the
patience of ecuador has reached its
limit i
install electronic equipment  of
distortion not allowed blocked the
security cameras of the vision of the
ecuador in the attacked the treaty
guards of the diplomatic headquarters accessed
without permission security files of
our embassy while deducing to be
incommunicado and rejects the
internet connection provided by the embassy
has a  mobile phone with which he
communicates with the outside world while
ecuador generously respected
the asylum conditions mr. assange
demanded the coexistence protocol in three different instances
and in all
cases the corresponding
authorities have agreed with ecuador on the
line  of our commitment to
respect what  s human rights and international law
request great britain to
guarantee that mr
assange had not extradited himself to a country
where he could suffer torture or the
death penalty the british government has
confirmed this in writing in compliance
with its own  rules finally
wikileaks the organization of Mr.
Las Años threatened the government of Ecuador two days ago
my government has nothing to fear and does not
act under threat 'ecuador is guided by
the principles of law complies
with international standards and cares for the
interests of Ecuadorians